[Music]
welcome back to uncensored last week I
criticized Elon Musk decision to allow
the massacre denying conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones to return to X formerly
Twitter some people weren't happy they
included the influential conservative
personality Steven Crowder this is what
he had to say on his show louder with
Crowder about me this brings us to uh
Pierce Morgan's rules for
me
he hosted Alex Jones on his very own
program this year Pierce Morgan doesn't
understand what freedom of speech is
Pierce Morgan has also hosted sahal
Shaheen the Taliban spokesperson geez
why shida and islamist extremist leader
Jeremy Corbin the anti-semitic labor
party leader just just Pierce stop I'm
sorry fraud fraud fraud fraud there we
go well in the spirit of Hosting very
controversial people on my free speech
platform I'm now joined by Steven
Crowder uh who can call me a free speech
hypocrite to my face Mr Crowder good day
to you how are you well thank you pierce
Merry Christmas and let me say off the B
I do actually appreciate about you your
audience may not know how rare this is
that you do these interviews live you
don't chop them up you actually have a
discussion and I've been advocating for
that my whole life so really I
appreciate it those are steps in the
right direction well they are and to be
honest with you the the debate about
what constitutes free speech and whether
there should be limits and if there
should be what they are I think is
really interesting and a lot of people
have strong opinions about this and I'm
perfectly happy to be proven wrong or to
at least have a debate with someone
who's got strong views that don't
necessarily tally with mine so I welcome
you to the program um let's start with
your assessment that I'm a free speech
hypocrite so articulate to me why you
believe
that I I believe the word I used there
was was fraud you earlier used hypocrite
did I okay I don't remember saying it
but I'll take your word for it and to
some degree I believe it look I I think
that in hosting a show uncensored and I
can't see you but I know you put up the
very festive uh holly leaf on the on the
globe there um it is incumbent upon you
you will say I believe in the concept of
free speech now I will I'll be very
clear in my definition of free speech
it's the Constitutional definition of
freedom of speech all speech is
permissible outside of a crime and we
have very clear parameters and these
have been affirmed by the Supreme Court
as to what that is that's a proactive
call for violence the crime is not the
speech the crime is the action causing
violence on purpose outside of that
everything is permissible but for a show
uncensored and I know that you've said
there's a difference between across the
pond there and obviously in the United
States we have a First Amendment that
you don't um how would you define
freedom of speech what is see I don't
think we're as far apart as you think I
mean you talk about the first amendment
not protecting for example crime it's a
little bit more complicated for example
it doesn't protect you if you
deliberately defame somebody and my
argument about Alex Jones in particular
was he's just been uh punished with over
a billion doll fine uh in one of the
biggest defamation cases in modern
American history for deliberately
telling lies about the families of the
poor victims of a Sandy Hook massacre
over a sustained period of time which
led to them getting direct harassment
and other criminal activities so I was
joining all the dots there of his
particular situation and I concurred
with Elon musk's original view when he
was asked about it when he first bought
Twitter last year which was he was not
going to allow him back on he's now
changed his mind but my opinion was
based on the Constitution of the United
States not protecting you if you are
guilty of
defamation well okay so I'm going to
have to take the rounds out of that
Magazine from how loaded that question
was and so much misinformation there and
that's the beauty of the freedom of
speech you can say that you can speak
misinformation and you have the right to
for example saying he knowingly lied
look I'm not in the business of
Defending everything that Alex Jones
everything that Alex Jones has said okay
but if you're going to say the 22
minutes out of 8,000 hours of broadcast
time for which he apologized
acknowledged that he was wrong
constitutes what you are saying is
proactively lying that is a very
dangerous Pres hang on hang on it's not
accurate Sten he did deliberately lie
for a sustained period of time for years
about these families he knew s tell me
how he deliberately lied he knew that he
he deliberately lied and he was found to
have Del Li how he deliberately lied and
by the way in his in his defense he how
he deliberately lied please in in his
defense he tried to play the first
amendment card and it was rejected by
the judge rejected tell me how he
deliberately lied please because he knew
that it wasn't a hoax he knew the
massacre had happened incorrect let's
listen to what he said that's incorrect
let's play Let's Play what he
said hook it's got inside job written
all over it Sandy Hook is a synthetic
completely fake with actors in my view
manufactured I couldn't believe it at
first people just instinctively know
that there's a lot of fraud going on uh
but it took me about a year with Sandy
Hook to come to grips with the fact that
the whole thing was fake whole thing was
fake repeat to a series of different
shows he did you still have an answer
you still have an answer that doesn't
prove that he knowingly lied anything
Alex Jones is wrong about a lie you're
very Jones is wrong about a liot St you
and I but he's
also it I'm going to respond to you you
and I disagree about many things we
agree about many too right just but on
this on this point you're a very smart
guy I wouldn't question that for a
moment you and I both know Alex Jones
knew that that was not faked Sandy Hook
you and I both know that so I have to
split the words out that you just tried
to place in my mouth I do not know that
I don't agree with the premise and you
have yet to prove it here's the beauty
though I don't have if you were to
commit defamation even if no it didn't
and even assuming gu with your audience
and I'm going to continue speaking as
though we're having a dialogue even
assuming that you don't discuss the Caps
that he would never pay out the far
lower settlement that they have decided
they would allow considering this will
go to a superior court and will get
thrown out even if you allow all of
those things here's the beauty of the
First Amendment here's the beauty of the
First Amendment even if you at one point
commit defamation you still don't
forfeit your right to speak going
forward don't fundamental human rights
and that's not why he was banned from
that's not why he was banned from
Twitter you know that he was banned from
TW he was banned from Twitter for having
a pop at some guy from CNN I don't care
about that I'm more interested in why
Elon Musk tweeted when he bought Twitter
and was asked will he bring back Alex
Jones he said no I won't allow somebody
back on having gone through the pain
himself of a child dying in his own arms
one of his children he wasn't going to
allow someone who profited from the pain
of dead children to be back on the
platform he then changed his mind which
he's allowed to do he owns the platform
X is a private company owned by Elon
Musk he could do what he likes with it
but they also have a series of rules
which are available on their website
which you can check about what is
allowed and not allowed and they will
deplatform you if you transgress those
rules and my point to you is
that the situation with Alex Jones
is that he was found guilty in an
American Court of defamation and yes
it's entirely down to Elon Musk that he
can bring him back but I agree with the
first version of Elon mus decision-
making not the second one based on a
completely undemocratic poll he put on
his own Twitter
feed well I I I agree with you that it
shouldn't be left to a democratic poll
because uh the first amendment is not
subject to a vote right right but the
but you accept the First Amendment of
the US Constitution has a number of
things which are excluded from
protection whether it's child
pornography fraud defamation there's a
whole list of things which you'll simply
but that has nothing that has nothing to
do with speech no no but you're you're
conflating but I think you mis you've
mischaracterized what I said then
because I've never said he hasn't got a
right to say what he wants he can say
what he likes I believe fundamentally in
anyone's right to say whatever they want
the question is accountability and the
US Constitution which you don't think I
know anything about but actually I know
a lot about and I I I didn't say you
don't know anything about it I really
don't
believe same um show you did you
basically said I don't know much about
the US Constitution because I'm not
American that's fine but I I have lived
and worked in America for 20 years I
have tried to really get a handle on the
US Constitution and on the issue of the
First Amendment it is a complicated
thing it's not as simple as saying you
can say whatever you want well it is
because it doesn't allow the unfettered
free speech with protection that you
suggesting do it absolutely does it
doesn't it absolutely does barring would
you like me to explain barring what I've
already outlined actual criminal
Behavior calling for violence against
other people for example Pierce look you
know that and and I'm saying this in
your defense for example you made your
your your joke about being a
two-spirited penguin right I thought it
was cute I think it was funny and I
understand the point that you were
trying to make okay you have had people
accuse you of C of creating violence
against trans you know that and I we
know it's absurd so who defines what is
actually calling for violence or if you
basically in a roundabout way cusing no
unless you called for violence you were
a twoed you keep saying that your only
barrier on free speech is crime and I
keep reminding you that Alex Jones was
found guilty of defamation and that is
one of the things that's not protected
by the First
Amendment no it's not protected in a CI
you can have civil damages and your
first amendment rights don't cease to
exist in other words you can you can pay
you can pay the piper for what you have
done in that so someone if someone at
some point if someone if someone accuses
you of defamation and let's say has a
suit leved against you that actually by
God is successful let's say that does
that forbid you from speaking publicly
thereafter no you don't lose it
fundamental human right not at all but
it does allow I'm exercising my rights
to free speech to say I think he
shouldn't be allowed back on X which was
the position of the owner of X until
last week so my point is that Elon Musk
has made two judgment calls about this
one I agreed with and one I didn't and
I'm exercising My Free Speech rights to
say I don't agree with it you you are
you are and I and I completely support
your right to that the problem is Elon
Musk changed his mind in the face of new
information and if we want to have
productive dialogues we need to all you
know what this is one thing I often ask
and by the way I think that none of this
is a got you for Twitter clicks I hope
to God it's not how often when you were
on CNN or how often uh when you were on
your uh Morning Show there in the UK or
how often do you see on any news network
someone say you know what new
information came out and I was wrong and
and I say that because you've done it
and I appreciate it you said you know
what if I knew what I know now about the
covid vaccine specifically that if you
get the covid vaccine you cannot
transmit it uh if I knew that that was
incorrect I wouldn't have espoused the
views that I did I think that's a
beautiful thing and I think the problem
that we have in today's society is not
wanting to allow people to be wrong to
make mistakes in the realm of Comedy
look good jokes and bad jokes come from
the same place sometimes you have to
risk something and it's
funny ex an opinion yeah but I agree
with you about all that sure I agree
with that I I tell that's really the
Bedrock of the show but I come back
again to why I had a particular issue
with the Alex Jones thing is unlike the
other circumstances you're describing in
his case he was found guilty of a
serious defamation against the Sandy
Hook families he was fined over a
billion dollar so far he's not paid a
dime of that money and you know Elon
Musk has made two calls on it like I
said the first one I agreed with I don't
think that people like Alex Jones should
be allowed an unchallenged unfettered
public platform to spew lies which are
done deliberately in my estimation to
spew lies challenged well are you out of
your
tree it's a c School anyone can say
anything they people can reply to him
but no one can have a direct challenge
to Alex Jones like I did when he came on
my show look like you you picked out for
example that he came on show Jeremy
Corbin Taliban spokesman and so on yes
because in each of those cases I put
them through the Mina right and I'm
prepared to have them on to give them a
hard time and challenge them you might
agree disagree with that but they're all
pretty volatile interviews uh but I was
able to challenge what I perceive to be
their untruth right I'll show you a clip
of the Corbin one to show you what I
mean have a look at this you seem to be
over concerned with with anti-Semitism
no no I did not should have Master St in
power it's actually you done yet it's
actually a critical
it's a critical question you done yet no
it's the question are you done yet
should they stay in this country says
they're a terror group do you agree and
should they stay in power listen I do
not approve support or welcome Hamas are
you prepared to call Ham a terror group
is it possible to have a rational you is
it possible come on answer that question
you answer it no it's my show you answer
my question now the point of playing
that clip other than to entertain you as
I'm sure it did um is that yes I hate
that CLI I hate everything about that
clip why do you hate
it I hate it because I don't like Jeremy
Corbin but I I think he's a bombastic
prick but I also think that you should
have let him finish speaking why because
then he would Express bad ideas that's
why I support freedom but actually in
the end I could tell very quickly he was
never going to give an answer and
therefore we were in a game of cat and
mouse which went on so long that the
viewer was leting no uncertain terms
what his answer actually was because
otherwise you just say Hamas or a terror
group it's not difficult and in fact two
days later he admitted Hamas for a
terror group that was his position but
only after I shamed him into doing it so
so look here's my question for you so
that's it so you want to shame people
into agreeing with you I would rather
just let them speak if they have bad
ideas not all I want to shame them into
giving an honest opinion what I what I
will really lose my rag about and I'm
sure you must be the same when people
just obfuscate and don't give a straight
answer to a straight simple question
then I will go after them if they give
an honest answer even if I don't agree
with it I respect that in fact I think
people who watch my show regularly will
see that is my position whether I agree
with them or not I have lots of people
on I don't really agree with but I find
the ones that I have respect for the
ones who give a straight answer to a
straight question so let me ask you a
straight question let me ask you a
straight question sure David Juke the
former KKK leader he's banned from
Twitter Elon Musk hasn't brought him
back should he be allowed to be back on
X don't throw that at me really you just
say I want to ask someone a straight
question you have me here I'm basically
a spectre I don't appear any you want to
ask me about David Duke yes he's because
he's banned from twitch should David
Duke be allowed back on X I'm not as
familiar with David Duke as I am with
Alex which is why I was able to point
out that you cannot prove that knowingly
lied about anything if David Duke has
called for the violence look if David
Duke has called for the violence uh
actions of violence against minority
groups then no if David Duke has
espoused horrible points of view that
can be refuted by the way not only by
other people who are on x but by the
community notes on X and on a platform
where people are free to speak on both
sides of the aisle then yes it doesn't
mean that I think he's anything other
than a Racist
Prick so I'm trying to work out can I
make one point yeah can I make one point
that I think is very this is really and
and hopefully we can agree on this
because I actually disagree with you
that Elon Musk can do whatever he wants
with his own platform it comes down to
this I think uh and if you look at the
historical record I think it is far more
dangerous for society to engage in a
culture of censorship of viewpoint
discrimination than it is to allow
people to speak freely barring the
committing of violent crimes I think
that we see a far worst a far worst
dystopia in our future if we allow the
government and these big Tech platforms
to determine who can speak and who
cannot and there we've seen some very
clear examples of this if you give me 30
seconds let me lay this out for you for
example I don't think they have the
right to uh for example Twitter Facebook
YouTube Here's why they benefit from
section 230 now I know you have a lot of
fans in UK they may not be familiar with
this let me explain what it means
they're basically treated like Public
Utilities meaning that they have
immunity from liability for someone
saying something on their platform for
example AT&T here in the states Can't
Ban you from their phone service because
you're racist an Tilly drops an end bomb
after a few drinks at Thanksgiving
they're a public utility these uh big
Tech platforms are treated as platforms
where they are not legally liable for
what is permitted but that allows them
to engage in Viewpoint discrimination
and then there is no accountability for
example the hunter Biden laptop story
which we know and this is why I make all
references publicly available because I
want to be held to account and I will be
held to account would have changed the
election if the government was not and
when I say colluding I mean Joe Biden
Jen saki Camala Harris uh Karen jeampier
calling for the removal of Joe Rogan
from Spotify calling for the removal of
of vaccine scientists by the way of mRNA
vaccine scientists from public platforms
if all information was allowed to be
transmitted freely like the platforms as
as they are treated under our legal
precedent here in section 230 guess what
Donald Trump would be president I'm
saying this as a matter of record and
fact millions of people would not have
gotten the MRNA vaccine specifically men
under 30 and lockdowns would have lasted
days weeks not years that is irrefutable
but you had the government and these
platforms deciding which views were
allowed and which views weren't and I
don't think I should be allowed you
should be allowed and certainly not the
government colluding with five companies
who control over 90% of the information
in the digital sphere it is terrifying
to me so you may think I'm an absolutist
I think I'm reasonable no no I don't I
actually don't think that's unreasonable
at all in fact I I have written numerous
columns about the outrage of the New
York Post having that initial expose of
Hunter Biden's laptop censored by
Twitter as it was then uh for two weeks
right before the 2020 election I know
I've I've said to Donald Trump to his
face never mind the stolen election
you keep trying to pretend
happened I said focus on that because
that probably swung the election because
it stopped the media investigating prop
properly what was going on with Hunter
Biden in Ukraine and what his father's
involvement would be I think that could
have swun the election so I absolutely
agree with
you let me give you a funny story about
and not only could it it would have
according to Dr Epstein do you realize
now I'm a comedian right this show
that's why I appreciate you said hey you
got a chuckle from our segment some of
it is tongue and cheek and I appreciate
that you recognize that and not try and
use you know you acknowledge that it's a
joke whether it's funny or not so as a
comedian the host of a comedy show Rudy
Giuliani was on this show and the first
time the public ever saw Hunter Biden's
laptop was on this show he brought it up
he goes I have the laptop here the FBI
came they threed my uh my my my my
offices they took everything but the lap
I go wait wait wait is that the hunter
Biden laptop he said yes episode is
banned suspended from YouTube think
about that think of how terrifying that
is it was an accident it's wrong it's
wrong let me ask you though yesterday on
your show you appeared wearing a t-shirt
saying Alex Jones was right changed my
mind so my question is what was he right
about oh gosh how much time do you have
well are you talking about Sandy
Hook no I'm not talking about Sandy Hook
he said he was wrong about Sandy Hook
right apologized for Sandy Hook when he
was sued he said he was WR eventually
but I'm saying obviously the shirt
wouldn't be addressing that if it's he
says I was wrong it would be awfully
daff toir you alluding to
then I'm alluding to for kryal if you
talk about intelligence agencies spying
on Americans if you talk about what
we've done with South American countries
uh as allowing the spread of STDs for
which Hillary Clinton apologized for if
you talk about nation building where
there have been underhanded deals with
Nations who don't have our best
interests at heart uh I mean it's you
know T take your pick I I don't believe
that for example George W Bush was next
to the Twin Towers with an Acme plunger
no I'm not that kind of a conspiracy
theorist but when Alex Jones said look
you are going to be coralled into social
media ghettos and lose your right to
speak he was right he's right about a
lot and I will say this he's been wrong
about plenty I am not here to defend
everything that Alex Jones has ever said
I'm willing to defend everything that I
have said on my program but that man is
exactly who you would expect him to be
he's a friend of mine and when everyone
else tucked tail and they ran I'm not
going to do that I'll tell him he's
wrong I'll tell you where I think he's
wrong but that man has a right to speak
just like I believe you have the right
to speak Pierce if you think they're not
going to come for you oh my word do you
have another thing coming and I hope
that you don't I genuinely hope that you
don't I mean I've had people say that I
was a hate speaker because I said soccer
was gay I do I think so you think
soccer's
gay homosexual
yes you know what that's a whole another
debate Stephen Crowder let's have a
debate about whether soccer is gay and
if it is by the way I would be happy to
embrace its homosexual side U well I
know you would I know you would but with
that accent you have to be careful
people take you seriously I think it's
great I think it's great if you're a
six-year-old girl or a homosexual from
Greece to quote Nick doollo yeah you
know the difference between our football
and your football we don't wear helmets
to protect ourselves we we're real men
over here you also don't allow contact
we're real men over here it's uh it's
there's no great padding or you know
great shoulder pads and helmets we just
get stuck into each other and that's the
difference americ Academy Awards you
like to wear helmets and carry guns we
just use these
guns but that's the whole a whole
another debate as well stepen Crow got
to leave it there it's been a good
debate I've actually enjoyed the tone of
this debate I think it's a really
interesting area free speech I think
ultimately we agree about more things
with free speech than we disagree but
let's keep the debate going thank you
for joining me mar Christmas Pierce I
appreciate it Angie all the
best